at the african union headquarters in the
ethiopian capital the first summit with
people instead of a video link in more
than two years the newly established
africa center for disease control africa
cdc is leading efforts to keep the
two-day summit covered free
the decision to hold the summit in
person
since the advent of the pandemic was
taken with the express
decision
that we are going to make it safe
top on the summit's agenda is how to
step up vaccination against covet 19 in
the continent
although covet vaccine supplies in
africa have risen significantly the
continent is struggling to expand
rollout with only 11 percent of the
population fully vaccinated
african heads of state and government
gathered here will also discuss another
epidemic of multiple crews in the
continent
emboldened by popular anger west african
military leaders in maligni and burkina
faso have carried out focus in 18 months
they followed military takeovers in
sudan and chad in 2021
more than 115 million africans are today
living under the rule of soldiers who
illegally ceased power the african union
with its often much hyped slogan of
african solutions to african problems
has been unable to do much to tackle
what some are calling an epidemic of
course
they're now increasing calls for more
action from the continental body
the resurgence of cruz has alarmed west
africa's remaining civilian leaders who
on friday called an emergency summit of
the regional economic community of west
african states echoes let's not really
fall into the illusion
that the military takeover will solve
the problem they cannot solve the
problem and they will not solve the
problem because we have seen it in the
past
the african union suspended maligni
burkina faso and sudan but not chad some
analysts warn the double standards could
have dire consequences
there is a breakdown in the social
contract between the government and the
people the governments are not
delivering for the people
but the benefits of economic growth are
going to those who are already rich and
the poor are continuing to be poor and
the marginal lies are continuing to be
marginalized with many african nations
facing major security threats
relentless humanitarian disasters and
millions of young people with no
prospects
reducing the number of crews might be a
tall order for the african union
muhammad al jazeera
by ethiopia